I had a Cyrex 10 test done. How do I know what to do with it? So, looking at that question,
I pulled up the Cyrex 10 test. What a person would look at. This is just page one of the four
five pages that come with the Cyrex test, 10 test. So the Cyrex array 10 test is a food, a mute
antibody screen. So it's testing antibodies to different peptides of proteins of different foods,
cooked foods, raw foods, and measuring whether you have antibodies to it. So this is page one of your
test. You have a really bad problem. Your gut is quite damaged. So greed would be normal. So if,
let's say, this top thing, it says egg white cooked, you are in the equivocal range. That means
so yellow is bad. Red is really bad. Let's use layman's terms here. Goat's milk, really bad. Soft,
cheese, plus hard cheese, really bad. Yogurt, bad. Do we have anything in the good range here on
death thing? So this is a person who is got a lot of immune issues, a lot of immune compromise.
There's literally nothing on this page that they can eat. This would be odd. There's a lot of
people that would do this test that everything on all the pages is agreed and they might have significant
health issues. Well, they don't have food antibodies. So that is not the piece that we need to work on.
But this is not an uncommon test for somebody with live or with any other auto-reud disease
that they may even think that they have no food sensitivities. They may think that, yeah, I am. I
got that strongest steel. I don't have any issues whatsoever. But yet, you look at the antibodies
against it. So this means literally, every time this person would eat goat's milk, they fire this
inflammatory response that's very high. That's causing a lot of inflammation in the gut.
And inflammation in the gut is going to damage the epithelial lighting of the gut.
Inflammation in the gut is going to cause inflammation in the brain and systemic inflammation.
And if there already is damage to the lighting of the gut, which definitely there is looking at this
panel right here, these antibodies can get across the damage gut. Well, into the blood, causing
an immune reaction to that peptide in the blood causing systemic inflammation. So this in itself,
food antibodies to different foods that you're eating those foods. If you have antibodies to
different foods and you're eating those foods, that can be a primary source of systemic eating
whole body inflammation. And you can't get better, the better, how many supplements you take, the better,
how many tools you are using, the better, how many good things you're doing. If you're
causing this literal house fire, every time you eat that thing, you're not going to get better.
So this Syrix testing to me is really important with any person that has any health
compromised because it really helps you understand what you could be doing to damage your body that you
might not even have symptoms. So this person might not have gut pain at all, kind of on this
prompt person probably does. But let's say the person everything was in green, but just these things,
the peas, the pea protein, and the popcorn was in red in this, let's say everything else was in
the green. But let's say they eat popcorn three times a week because it's just their family treat,
but they don't notice any problems, they don't have any stomachache, but every time they eat popcorn,
they cause this ramped up inflammation, this literal bonfire in their gut that is or in their blood
stream that is causing their health problems. It can be causing their rheumatoid arthritis,
it can be it can be causing their Hashimoto's, it can be causing that there is something that they're
attributing to their Lyme disease or their their MS, and they never put the two things together. So
very big doing this kind of testing because you can find things out that you can really, really help
people with. So you run that test and you go to six, I never had any stomachache when I ate popcorn,
I had no idea. And this person then takes popcorn out of their diet. Let's pretend that you know,
they had popcorn pee, cooked peas and pea protein and they were doing a pea protein shake every day too.
And they remove those things from their diet from a period of time and their whole inflammatory
process goes down. Now I believe that this is just one facet in a person's health. There's other
things going on. Maybe they have biotoxids, maybe they have heavy metals, maybe they have you know,
Lyme disease, maybe they have damaged blood brain barrier, maybe they have a damaged lung barrier,
maybe they have mold issues too. So you have to deal with as many of these facets as possible if
you want to get better. And I know it gets exhausting. But the problem that people have and the
mistake that people make is they think that they're just missing this one piece and they do that one
piece and then they get really disappointed because they didn't see the results. But they dropped
everything else and that's an error. So if a person's got a test that looks like this example here,
then you know, they have a really bad damage barrier. So they're got barrier needs to be healed.
So just going off all these foods is not going to fix their problem. They need to be doing stuff to
heal. They're gut at the same time. And that is just absolutely essential. But again, it's not the only
thing. If they have a damaged gut barrier, they probably have a damaged blood brain barrier. They're
probably have a damaged chalneular barrier in the lungs. And those things need to be healed too. So
you have to do a lot of things concurrently to really see the benefit and it takes time for your
body to heal. And you want to do a retest after a period of time to see those changes. So
I do have a video on the different arrays that will help you in array 10 that goes into more detail
than I'm talking about in this. But I think this will give you a nice, full book.